GOOD MORNING THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
COME TO ORDER. I IN RESPONSE TO
COVERT NINETEEN- AND IT'S
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE IN THE
STATE CAPITOL BUILDING TODAY.
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TO THIS HEARING ROOM. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS.
877-692-8958 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO TWO THREE NINE
ONE. SEVEN ZERO. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
ANDORRA COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME. AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER HE WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND
YOU'RE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. AND
PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE- AS THE
CHAIR ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL.
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEDIAN
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS. VIEWED WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT THEIR HEARING. IT
IS CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
NINE BILLS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY
WITH THREE MEASURES ON CONSENT.
THE CONSENT BILLS ARE SCA TWO
BY SENATOR ALAN. AB THREE
NINETEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY
THE IRS. AND AB FIFTEEN NINETY
ONE. BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ELECTIONS. I SEE THAT WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISHED YET SO WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD THE UP WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. AS OUR COLLEAGUES I
WONDER HERE INTO THE HEARING
ROOM. SO BUT I ASKED THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
ONE OKAY I DON'T LIKE I WONDER
I. ALL ALL RIGHT THE CHAIRLIFT
INCORRECT THERE ARE NO
WONDERING SENATORS HERE IF THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
AS A REMINDER THE MEMBERS
PLEASE REMEMBER TO TURN ON AND
SPEAK INTO THE MICROPHONE.
GLAZER PRESENT. GLAZER PRESENT
NIELSEN. HERTZBERG LEYVA HERE
LIVING HERE NEWMAN HERE NEWMAN
HERE. ALL RIGHTS WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND I DID CHECK WITH THE
VICE CHAIR- WE TEND TO LIKE TO
BEGIN OUR COMMITTEE WITH
REPRESENTATION AND THE VICE
CHAIR HE IS DOUBLE BOOKED IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE HAS INDICATED
IT'S OKAY TO PROCEED- WITH THE
AGENDA TODAY ALTHOUGH WE'LL
CERTAINLY KEEP THE ROLE OPEN SO
HE AND OTHERS CAN'T
PARTICIPATE- MEMBERS WE HAVE AS
I MENTIONED A CONTENT CALENDAR
BEFORE YOU- ANY QUESTIONS OR
ISSUES ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IF NOT COULD I GET A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR MOVED.
CENTER LEYVA HAS MOVED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SO WE WILL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION CALL FOR A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH INCLUDES
A C. TO A B. THREE ONE NINE
MAYBE FIFTEEN NINETY ONE
GLAZER. AYE GLAZER AYE NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG LEYVA HI THERE ARE A
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN HI RIGHT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CURLIEST
REVOTES WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WE WANT TO
WELCOME OUR FIRST AUTHOR TO THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
WELCOME YOU ARE HERE TO PRESENT
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX IN THE
BEGINNING THEY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY WELCOME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
CENTERS AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
WOULD PERMIT THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA NDL HAMBURG UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO CONDUCT A
SPECIAL ELECTION IN ORDER TO
PROCEED WITH ITS TRANSITION
FROM AT LARGE TO FLY TRUSTEE
EVERY ELECTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OF EDUCATION. IN
ORDER TO COMPLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE. DURING
THE NOVEMBER THIRD TWENTY
TWENTY GENERAL ELECTION MEASURE
G. WHICH APPEARED ON THE BALLOT
SOUGHT TO REMOVE FROM THE CITY
CHARTER ALL REFERENCES. TO THE
L. HAVE A UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. HOWEVER MEASURE G.
ONLY APPEAR ON THE BALLOTS OF
THE VOTERS RESIDING IN THE CITY
OF ALHAMBRA AND NOT ON THE
BALLOTS OF VOTERS IN ALHAMBRA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. WHO
RESIDE OUTSIDE OF THE CITY'S
BOUNDARIES. UNDER EXISTING LAW
CHARTER AMENDMENT FOR CITY MUST
BE SUBMITTED TO THE VOTERS. AT
AN ESTABLISHED STATEWIDE
GENERAL ELECTION SO
CONSEQUENTLY THE CITY OF-
HOWEVER AND THE- SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE PROHIBITED FROM
CONDUCTING A SPECIAL ELECTION.
TO AMEND THE CHARTER PRIOR TO
THE NEXT STATEWIDE ELECTION ON
NOVEMBER THE EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THEREFORE WE NEED
TO CREATE A SPECIAL EXCEPTION
AND THE GOVERNMENT CODE TO
PERMIT THE CITY OF ALL HAMBRE.
AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
CONDUCT A SPECIAL ELECTION
BEFORE THE NEXT STATEWIDE
GENERAL ELECTION. TO DO THIS I
HAVE ADDED AN URGENCY CLAUSE.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT DISTRICT
BILL WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I.THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SELLING AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT- YOU HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS MISTER DEAN LOGAN FROM
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. THAT
IS CORRECT LIKE TO ASK THE
OPERATOR TO PLEASE- ALLOW
MISTER LOGAN ACCESS TO OUR
HEARING. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
RESTORING YOUR LINE IS OPEN
SERVICE CALL IS GOING TO. GREAT
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING SHARE
GLAZER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DEAN LOGAN
AND I AM THE REGISTRAR RECORDER
COUNTY CLERK FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TESTIFYING THIS MORNING
ON BEHALF OF OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHILD
FOR OFFERING AS WELL AS THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND CITY OF ALL HAMBRE
FOR CO SPONSORING THE BILL WITH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX SUPPORT THE EFFORT
AND INTENT OF THE ALHAMBRA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
ESTABLISH DISTRICT BASED
ELECTION FOR TRUSTEE IS ALIGNED
TO THE FAIR AND DISTRIBUTED
REPRESENTATION PROVISIONS OF
THE CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS
ACT. AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX ALSO
ADDRESSES THE UNIQUE SITUATION
WHERE OUTDATED REFERENCES IN
THE CITY OF ALHAMBRA CHARTER
REGARDING THE ALHAMBRA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT'S CONFLICT WITH
THE DISTRICT ACTIONS TO ADOPT
THE TRUSTEE AREA ELECTION
MODEL. TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
THE THIRTY PLAYED THE MEASURE
ON THE BALLOT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION TO REMOVE
OUTDATED LANGUAGE AND
REFERENCES TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
AN ERROR IN INTERPRETING THE
THIRTIETH ELECTION RESOLUTION
THE MEASURE ONLY APPEARED ON
BALLOTS FOR VOTERS WITHIN THE
CITY OF ALHAMBRA AND DID NOT
APPEAR ON BALLOTS FOR VOTERS IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WHO RESIDE
OUTSIDE THE BOUNDARY. THEREFORE
THE MEASURE MUST BE PLACED ON
THE BALLOT AGAIN IN THE FUTURE
ELECTION WAITING UNTIL THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO STATE GENERAL
ELECTION WOULD DELAY THE
DISTRICT EFFORT TO ESTABLISH
TRUST THE AREAS AND ALIGN THEIR
ELECTION MODEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT
PRIOR TO THE NEXT ELECTION OF%
THE GOVERNING BOARD MEMBERS. AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX WOULD ENABLE
THE CITY TO CONDUCT A SPECIAL
ELECTION ON IN ANY OF TABLETS
SELECTION DATE ASKED ABOUT THE
BY ELECTION CODE THEREBY
ALLOWING THE DISTRICT TO
PROCEED WITH THE TRANSITION
FROM AT LARGE TO TRUST THE AREA
ELECTIONS CONSISTENT WITH BOTH
ELECTION AND EDUCATION CODE
REQUIREMENT THAT ORIGINALLY
INTENDED. BASED ON THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT
PREPARING DISTRIBUTED
REPRESENTATION ON LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARD THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
LOGAN WE'RE GONNA GO FOR OTHER.
WITNESSES WHO WERE IN FAVOR OF-
AB FIFTY FORTY TO TEST. THIRTY
IS THERE ANY HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY. WHICH TO DO
SO. WELL THERE'S ANOTHER LEAD-
LEAD SUPPORT WHEN IS ON THE
LINE OKAY I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
ANOTHER LEAD OFF WITNESS IN
SUPPORT ON THE LINE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU KNOW WHO THAT IS I
BELIEVE ARE HE IS THE COUNCIL
FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT- I GET
THE NAME OF THE TENANT IS AT
FAULT. MISTER SALT IS TO SELL-
OUR MODERATOR IF YOU CAN LOCATE
MR SAUL. ASKING TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY NOW. MISTRESS ALL
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MAN YOU SEE.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JONATHAN FAULT AND I'M
AN ATTORNEY AT THE EDUCATIONAL
OFFER MCCAIG IMPROVEMENTS
ACROSS OUR FIRM REPRESENTS THE
OPTIMAL UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
IN CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND VIDEO
CAMERAS PLEASED TO CO SPONSOR
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY SIX. YEAH
HAVE FIFTY CHARTER CURRENTLY
GOVERNED SCHOOL DISTRICT
ELECTIONS AND OTHER ADDITIONAL
SCHOOL BOARD FUNCTIONS WHILE
REQUIRING THE USE OF AN AT
LARGE SELECTION METHOD. THE
CHARTER ALSO IMPOSES
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
TRACKING TERMS OF OFFICE.
FILING AT SHOWING THE BACON
CHEESE AND WHERE AND HOW TO
FILE NOMINATION PAPERWORK THAT
IS DIFFERENT FROM STATE LAW
DOES NOT APPLY TO THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA. A
DIFFICULT TRANSITION TO A
DISTRICT ACROSS THE AREA BASED
COLLECTION SYSTEM TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CVR RIGHT.
AND TO BE TREATED ALL OTHER
AFFECT LIKE MOST OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE. IN
NOVEMBER AT THE DISTRICT'S
REQUEST THE CITY PLACE THE
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT TO REMOVE
ALL REFERENCES. TO THE DISTRICT
WITHIN THE CITY CHARTER. BUT
FORTUNATELY YOU TO COUNTY
CLERICAL ERROR THE BALLOT
MEASURE IS ONLY AVAILABLE TO
FIGURE ACCIDENT AND NOT ALL
DISTRICT RESIDENTS AS REQUIRED.
DR THAT AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
WOULD PERMIT THE CITY TO
PLACEMENT DENTICLE MEASURE ON
THE BALLOT THIS YEAR'S
NOVEMBER. AND IF APPROVED
ALLOWED YOU TO COMPLETE- LIKE
TRANSITION. IT HIGHLY MANNER.
AND TO HOLD AN ELECTION TO THE
COUNTY NOT THE CITY CURRENTLY
REQUIRE EVEN APPROXIMATELY.
HALF OF THIS RESIDENTS LIVE
OUTSIDE THE CITY. THE CITY
COUNTY AND DISTRICT- AND IT
GETS CO SPONSORS AND- THE
COMMITTEES I BUILT ON AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SALT. SO GOING BACK TO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- I SEE NO
ONE ELSE HERE IN OUR HEARING
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
MODERATOR CAN SEE IF ANYONE IS
ON THE LINE AND WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN JIM
ON THE PHONES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
PRESS ONE. ZERO AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER A SECURE LINE NUMBER OF
THE CALL. WILL OPEN YOUR LINE
THROUGH THE STATE YOUR NAME.
AND AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL ONCE
AGAIN. WE'RE SUPPORT OF AB ONE
FIVE FOUR SIX PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. AND WE'RE GOING OUT TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT ROCKERS OF
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COLLECTION
ALEXION'S OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT PERSON MY ACUTE
LINE SEVENTEEN. HI THIS IS
BRIAN- CALLING ON BEHALF OF
FOOTBALL FANS THE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX THANK YOU. I
ONCE AGAIN FOR SUPPORT THE
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WHATEVER
ELSE YOU MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO PEOPLE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTERS IN QUEUE TERRIFIC
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
SO WE'RE NOT WE'RE GOING TO NOW
GO TO. OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX THERE'S NO PRIMARY
OPPOSITION LISTED IN OUR
MATERIALS- LOOK TO ANYONE HERE
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WHICH IS TESTIFYING OPPOSITION.
C. NINE MODERATOR CAN YOU ASK
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
OPPOSITION TO FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
PLUS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE
AGAIN OPERATE WILL GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER THAT'S YOUR LONG
LINE OF THE TO BE CALLED
PROPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR
WITH THAT COMMENT LEFT
ANNOUNCEMENT WE HAVE NO COMMENT
TO SECURE. GREAT THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU RICHARD GUY ASSEMBLY MEN
SHALL- GLAD TO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE I ACTUALLY HAVE. A
RELATED BILL. THAT IS MOVING
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY RIGHT NOW
AS BEFORE FORTY TWO WHICH WOULD
ACTUALLY SOLVE THIS PROBLEM ON
A MORE PERMANENT BASIS- THIS IS
CLEARLY. A BIT ANACHRONISTIC-
SERVEST- THE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED- FINANCIAL PLANS WITH
THE BILL TODAY BUT LOOKING
FORWARD TO MY BILL PASSING ITS
ALL THE FOLKS LIKE MR LOGAN. IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THIS
PROBLEM IN THE FUTURE IS THE.
MOVE TO DISTRICT ELECTIONS
THANKS. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR-
SENATOR NEWMAN- TRYING TO READ
THAT IS A MOTION WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE ONE PLEASE YES. OKAY
CENTER NEWMAN HAS MOVED THE
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND REFLECT I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND LASTLY-
CONSOLE TO CALL THE ROLL ON AB-
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX TO PASS TO.
IS THE FLOOR. EDUCATION OKAY
SIX OF THE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB FIFTY FORTY FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX MOTIONS TOO FAST BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION GLAZER AYE GLAZER
AYE. NIELSEN HERTZBERG LEYVA
AYE FLAVOR AYE NEWMAN NEWMAN HI
ARE THE BILL CURRENTLY ENJOYS
THREE VOTES IN FAVOR ONLY THE
ROLE OF HER FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
SOMETHING I THINK YOU SENATORS
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
IN OUR AGENDA TO- ITEM THREE.
AB SEVENTY FIFTY FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY HERE.
RIGHT WE CALL THIS OFFICE LET
HIM KNOW THAT WE'RE READY TO
HEAR HIS TESTIMONY- I'LL MOVE
ON I KNOW THAT- I HAVE NUMBER
FIVE S. C. A. ONE BITES CENTER
HERTZBERG. WILL BE HEARD TODAY
SENATOR IS NOT PRESENT YET SO
WE'LL WAIT HIS ARRIVAL- I THINK
THE SAME IS IN PLACE FIRST
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN WHO IS
PRESENTING EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
SIX I DON'T SEE HIM HERE I
THINK HE'S GOING TO BE ARRIVING
A LITTLE BIT LATER- DO WE HAVE
A- ANYONE PRESENTING THE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS BILL.
CONSULTANT THAT WOULD BE HE
PRESENTED BILLS WELL ALL RIGHT-
ONLY ONE OTHER ITEM- THAT WE
STILL COULD HEAR RIGHT NOW AND
IT'S ITEM NUMBER NINE AS CA
FIVE BY SENATOR GLAZER- SO
SINCE HE'S PRESENT- RIGHT. I'M
GONNA TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO MY
SENIOR COLLEAGUE- CENTER LEYVA
HANDED HER SHE WILL HELP I'LL
ALLOW THE PRESENTATION OF THIS
BILL. RIGHT OKAY. AND LASER YOU
WERE GOING 2% S. C. A. FIVE
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT FROM YOUR
SEATS PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU
ARE READY THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA
SCA FIVE WILL INCREASE THE
VOTING RIGHTS OF THE STUDENT
MEMBERS OF THE UC BOARD OF
REGENTS BY ALLOWING THE
EXISTING NONVOTING STUDENT
REGION TO RECEIVE VOTING POWER
GIVING BOTH STUDENTS VOTING
RIGHTS THIS WOULD ONLY TAKE
PLACE OF APPROVED BY THE VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA. CURRENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES THAT THE UC BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE UC BOARD OF
REGENTS. WHICH CONSISTS OF
TWENTY FIVE MEMBERS SEVEN OF
WHOM ARE EX OFFICIO MEMBERS.
EIGHTEEN APPOINTED MEMBERS- BY
THE GOVERNOR AND APPROVED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. IN
ADDITION THE UC BOARD OF
REGENTS HAVE APPOINTED TO
STUDENT REGION'S TO THE BOARD
ONE WITH BUILDING POWER. AND
ONE WITHOUT. THIS BILL WOULD
THAT'S BOTH STUDENTS WITH A
VOTE AT THE BOARD. AND ALLOW
THE STUDENT REGION TO VOTE FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THEIR TERM. AS
WE ALL KNOW STUDENTS BRING
DIVERSE EXPERIENCES AND SPECIAL
PERSPECTIVES- TO THE TABLE
THEY'RE UNIQUELY POSITIONED
OFFER- THE BORDER REGION STATED
DAY FEEDBACK FROM THEIR
UNIVERSITIES. THEY KNOW HOW
OTHER INSTITUTIONS FUNCTION IN
MANY IMPORTANT PLACES- THIS
MEASURE WILL ALLOW THAT
ADDITIONAL STUDENT REGION TO
SERVE. A TERM AS A FULL VOTING
MEMBER. AND BE IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION TO REPRESENT THE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS- FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM. TODAY I
HAVE- JAMAL WILL WALK KILL THE
CURRENT STUDENT REGION. AND
JOSH WILL LUIS LUIS UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS HERE TO TESTIFY.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER GLAZER BOB YOU HAVE YOUR
TWO MINUTE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES ARE LISTED. IN THE
ARMS CHAIR GLAZER HOW MANY
MINUTES TO GENERALLY GIVE TWO
VERY GOOD SO- MISTER JAMAL WILL
CALL E. AND MR JOSH LEWIS YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES I WILL
LET YOU DECIDE WHO'S. GONNA GO
FIRST PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING I'LL GO
HADN'T HAPPENED FIRST
RESEARCHER BOB MARSHALL. WELL I.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TERRY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR HEARING-
THAT. I AM- AS I MENTIONED MY
NAME IS JAMAL MARSHALL I'M
CURRENTLY WITH FORTY SIX
STUDENT REGENT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND AS
A PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SECONDARY PRIMARY AND POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION I COULD NOT
BE PROUDER THAN TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS THEIR STUDENT
REGENT FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I HAVE THAT.
ORTEGA'S ALL TRY TO ENJOY IT
WHILE IT LASTS- IN MY CAPACITY
AS HEAD THE BOSTON OPPORTUNITY
TO SERVE AS THE CHAIR FOR THE-
SPECIAL COMMITTEE OF BASIC
NEEDS THAT. ESTAN GREAT SUCCESS
AND GRANTED EQUITY RESTRICTED
TO OUR STUDENTS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA YEAH.
THE WELCOME. AND AMAZING WORK
FOR OUR STUDENTS ARAFAT. BUT IT
IS IN A MANNER WAY THE OF THE
THAT WOULD SPAN IN STUDENT
VOICE THROUGH THE POSITION THAT
I HAD. I ALSO GREAT PARTNERS ON
EITHER SIDE OF ME TO DO IT AND
WE CAN AND STUDENT REGENT FINE
ME THE TRICKY ABOUT THAT THOUGH
IS THAT WE ONLY HAVE TO VOTE
FOR ONE YEAR- AND THAT MAKES
ALL REPRESENTATION ARE REALLY
TRICKY GIVEN THE CONCURRENT-
NATURE OF OUR MEETING BECAUSE
I'M SURE YOU'RE FAMILIAR. SO
WHAT THAT MEANS PRACTICALLY
EXCEPT WHEN IT IS THE CASE THEN
WE GO INTO OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUR OTHER DESIGNATE CALLS WITH
DIFFERENT COMMITTEE IS ONLY ONE
VOTE OR A STUDENT THAT'S
PRESENT AND ANY GIVEN MEETING
AT ANY TIME HAVE THE COMMENTS.
A PARCEL THAT OUT-
STRATEGICALLY I WOULD FIND. IT
THAT- DO BURKE YOU CAN REALLY
MEDIC TO THE BENEFIT THE POWER
OF THIS. VOICE AND THE REASON
THEY- ARE. HIS BECAUSE- ALL.
THE DID SOME OF THE MOST POWER.
I'LL VOICE ON. THE PHONE WITH-
REALLY APPRECIATE. IT I A
COUPLE YOU. ACT LET'S NOT- ON
THE APPROVAL OF. WHO ARE ACTOR
WITH HIS NAY OF THIS AN
EMPLOYER WHAT ABOUT THE TIME
WITH THAT BALL BUT EXPAND IN
THE FUTURE WHAT MIGHT BE DONE
WITH MORE ACT REP. ALL
CORPORATE BANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TO REFER THANK
YOU VERY MUST MUCH MISTER- WALK
L. I. MISTER LEWIS YOU'RE UP
NEXT PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
STRICTLY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF MY INSTRUCTOR I
HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING AT
THE CARE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AT THE AGE THAT I
CAN DO FOR YOU TODAY
RESPECTFULLY AFTER AYE VOTE ON
WHAT THE MOST IMPORTANT STUDENT
PRIORITY PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT FIVE. UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE YOU YOU BORDER REGION HAS
THE ABILITY TO ALLOW ONE MEMBER
TO HAVE VOTING POWER ON THE
BOARD. BUT YOU JUST HEARD VAULT
THAT BUT THE FACT OF THE
STUDENT ORGANIZED MOVEMENT
NEARLY NINETEEN SEVENTY
EXERCISE DISABILITY BY
APPOINTING ONE STUDENT. WITH TO
YOUR CART THE FIRST YEAR THAT
TIME THE DIDN'T LACK VOTING
POWER AND SHARED A REGION THAT
IT MIGHT. BE A FIVE WOULD MAKE
THE DISCRETIONARY POWER OF THE
PORTS WILL POINT THE STUDENT
MANDATORY AND WE. BOATING POWER
TO THE SECOND. THANK THIS JUST
MEANS THAT THE- REGION
DESIGNATE WITH. OLD VOTER
MEMBERS THE BOARD IN THE FIRST.
YEAR THE NEW RESCUED BY IT'S
CLEAR. THE INFECTION OF THE
STATE OF THE- POPULAR. AND YOU
YOU HAVE BY ROCK IT. WITHOUT
ANY CO. CHANGES OCCURRED
PATIENTS. FURTHERMORE MANY OF
THE- MADE BY YOUR SUPPORT
REGENTS HAPPENING MAYBE IT AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT THE COOKING.
AT THE SAME TIME. THE CO
INABILITY OF THE VOTER STUDENT
RICH INTO QUITE A ONCE. WITHIN
CERTAIN AND BOTH OUT OF ALL THE
MAKING. OF COURT. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE REGION AT
BEHIND WOULD BE GREAT IF
ACCEPTED ABOARD. IN A BEAUTY OF
A- IT WAS DINNER REGION TO. THE
BASE NEEDS CAN FIRST. FOR WITH
THE REIMAGINE I COULD. THAT IT
THAT YOU SEE. IT WAS DURING TO
REPEAT STOPPED. HIGH AND IT WAS
IN A REGION SPOKE A LOT OF. THE
NEED TO DOUBLE THE GRANTED
REFORM ACT GRANT IN ORDER TO IN
AREN'T. REMAINS ACCEPTABLE CALL.
BECAUSE OF THIS IN ASKING YOUR
I. TODAY STUDENT ARE OFTEN FOR
YOUR READ. TO THE FUNDING
MISSION UP YOUR- TO PROVIDE.
FOR ALL. THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROVED TO VOTING STUDENT
MEMBERS FOR BOTH THE CSU AND
PTP GOVERNING BOARD. AND WE
TODAY HAPPY TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE SAME FOR
YOU THE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTION. THANK YOU MISTER
LEWIS WILL NOW MOVE HERE TO
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE FOR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE
UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN. SUPPORT OF S. C. EIGHT.
FIVE PLEASE. THANK YOU THE
SHERPA'S. SO PLEASED ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR- AGAIN THAT'S ONE.
AT THIS. PLEASE. I SHOWN ONLINE
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WE HAVE NO ONE
LISTED AS LEAD OPPOSITION WE
WILL GO HERE TO ROUTE THIRTY
ONE AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE-
MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU QUEUE
UP ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION S. C. A. FIVE PLEASE.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU PRESS THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN ONE AND
THEN ZERO PLEASE. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. ON THE PHONES
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I'D LIKE TO COMMEND THE TWO
STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
AND THEN WITH THAT MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH US
SENATOR GLAZERS WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN- MISTER
CONSULTANT. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. RECEIVE FIVE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED THE FIRST
BE REFERRED WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GLAZER HI THERE I NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG LEYVA AYE FLAVOR AYE
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT MAN I. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN BACK
TO YOU THANK YOU- CENTER LEYVA
YEAR US THE STEWARDSHIP OF THIS
HEARING- WITH THE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR AUTHORS NOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. I WOULD ASK THEM TO
COME TO THE COMMITTEE. HEARING
ROOM BEFORE WE ADJOURN SO WE
CAN HEAR HIS BILL. AND WHILE WE
WAIT A MINUTE BUT THE COMMITTEE
INTO RECESS FOR- HOPEFULLY A
BRIEF MOMENT SO WE'RE GOING TO
RECESS
YEAH COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS BACK TO ORDER WE
HAVE A WONDERFUL AUTHORED. I
JUST TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN WELCOME. I UNDERSTAND
YOU PRESENTING TO BILLS TODAY
ITEM SIX EIGHTY SEVEN NINE SIX
AND THEN ITEM SEVEN AB FIFTEEN
NINETY. RIGHT SHALL WE BEGIN
WITH AB SEVEN NINE SIX AS GOOD
A BILL AS ANY MISTER CHAIR
RIFIC WELCOME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS. SB SEVEN
NINETY SIX SEEKS TO IMPROVE AND
REFINE THE CALIFORNIA NEW MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM TO ENSURE ITS
CONTINUED SUCCESS AND
EFFECTIVENESS. I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THE VERY
THOROUGH ANALYSIS AND FOR
IDENTIFYING COMING OVER TO OF
THE ANALYSIS THE POTENTIAL
AMBIGUITY IN THE FIVE DAY
TRIGGER. I'M HAPPY TO CLARIFY
THE INTERNAL D. QUOTE IN AN
ELECTION BE REPLACED WITH A
QUOTE FOR A STATEWIDE OR
FEDERAL ELECTION. WHEN
CALIFORNIA LAUNCHED THE NEW
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM APRIL
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. BECAME THE
LARGEST AND ONE OF THE FIRST
STATES TO IMPLEMENT AUTOMATIC
VOTER REGISTRATION THROUGH THE
DMV. NEW MOTOR VOTER MADE IT
EASIER FOR ELIGIBLE VOTERS TO
REGISTER OR UPDATE THEIR
REGISTRATION WHEN COMPLETING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE. AND STATE
IDENTIFICATION CARD
APPLICATIONS. AND IT IS PLAYED
AN INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN CLOSING
VOTER REGISTRATION GAPS AS WELL
AS IMPROVING THE ACCURACY OF
VOTERS MAILING ADDRESSES. WHICH
IS CRUCIAL IN INCREASING ACCESS
TO VOTE BY MAIL VOTING. BETWEEN
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF MORE THAN
TWELVE MILLION IT NEW OR
UPDATED VOTER REGISTRATIONS
RESULTED FROM THE NEW MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM. DESPITE THE
SUCCESSES AND CHALLENGES WITH
MODERNIZING THE MOTOR VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS CONTINUE
TO LIMIT THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS. AT ITS HEART AB
SEVENTY SIX WOULD APPLY LESSONS
LEARNED AND ADAPTED FEDERAL AND
ADOPT FEDERAL MOTOR VOTER
TIMELINES. FOR TIME THE
TRANSMITTAL OF VOTER
REGISTRATION INFORMATION FROM
THE DMV TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE. AS WELL AS CODIFYING
NUMBER OF BEST PRACTICES FROM
THE ONGOING LEGAL SETTLEMENT
INCLUDING DATA REPORTING ON
PROCESSING TIMES TRAINING OF
DMV AND SECRETARY OF STATE
STAFF. IN MAINTAINING
COORDINATORS AT THE DMV AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO MONITOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL AND
STATE MOTOR VOTER LAWS. SB
SEVEN NINETY SIX WILL ENSURE
THAT THE PROGRESS MADE UNDER
OUR NEW MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM
WILL CONTINUE. AND KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S VOTERS WROTE VOTER
ROLLS ACCURATE AND UP TO DATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE- AND WITH ME TODAY
PROBABLY ON THE PHONE. OR KIANA
AWESOME AWESOME ON FOR ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CALLING
BECAUSE IN BERNIE STONE SO FOR.
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU. THANK
YOU SOMEONE AND- MODERATOR HE
COULD ASK THOSE TWO WITNESSES
TO PLEASE- BEGIN WE PROVIDE TO
TWO MINUTES FOR EACH OF THEM
AND WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY.
GOOD MORNING SURE GLAZER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JONATHAN MONTANA AND I'M THE
PROGRAM MANAGER AT CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE. A NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
BUILDING AN INCLUSIVE DEMOCRACY
WITH EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX WE
ARE CONTINUING THE FIGHT TO
CREATE A REPRESENTATIVE
ELECTRIC WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA. IN
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION.
CALIFORNIA'S MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM HAS STREAMLINED THE
VOTER REGISTRATION IF THE DMZ.
THE PROGRAM'S ROLLOUT THE
PROGRAM HAS ADDED OVER THREE
MILLION VOTERS TROUBLED. AND
HELP KEEP OUR VOTER ROLLS
ACCURATE. DESPITE THESE
ADVANCES MORE THAN THREE
MILLION ELIGIBLE. IN CALIFORNIA
REMAIN UNREGISTERED A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
WHICH INCLUDE UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS. FURTHER THE ACCURACY OF
OUR VOTER ROLLS IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT AS MORE
CALIFORNIANS CAN EXPECT TO
RECEIVE THEIR BALLOTS BY MAIL.
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY SIX WITH A
LOT OF FIVE BEST PRACTICES AND
ALLOW FOR CONTINUED OVERSIGHT
AND IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR MOTOR
VOTER PROGRAM. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE. VOTE FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS BERNICE DOWNSIDE FOR AND I'M
A FAILURE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
I'M PROUD BECAUSE BONTA BABY
SEVEN NINETY SIX ACLU AND OUR
PARTNERS HAVE SPENT MANY YEARS
ADVOCATING TO INCREASE THE
FAIRNESS AND EFFICIENCY OF THE
MOTOR VOTER SYSTEM IN RECENT
YEARS THE ADVOCACY HAS TAKEN
THE FORM OF A SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THE DMB AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. UNDER THAT
ADAMANT THE DMV AND SECRETARY
OF THEM PROVIDING DETAILED
MONTHLY REPORT ABOUT PROMISING
A VOTER REGISTRATION
APPLICATIONS AT THE DMV AS WELL
AS REGULARLY MEETING WITH US TO
DISCUSS THIS REPORT THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT THESE REQUIREMENTS
CREATIVITY. ALLOWED
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY AND
COLLABORATIVELY RESOLVE
SYSTEMIC ISSUES. THAT WE'RE
DEALING VOTER REGISTRATION.
THEY ALSO SIGNAL IMPROVED CAL
COMPLY WITH AND FEDERAL TAX LAW.
UNFORTUNATELY HOWEVER THESE
REQUIREMENTS BUDGET BEEN SO
CRITICAL TO TRANSFORMING THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM INTO THE
SUCCESS THAT IT IS TODAY WELL
EXPIRE IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AB SEVENTY SIX WILL CODIFY
BEST PRACTICES ALREADY IN PLACE
THE DM B. AS A RESULT OF THE
SETTLEMENT. AND CREATE MORE
CLARITY AND CONSISTENCY ACROSS
THE NBA WORKSTREAM. EITHER
COMMONSENSE PROVISIONS LIKE THE
CHOIR IN BMB TO CONTINUE
TRACKING AND REPORTING
REGISTRATION PROCESSING TIME.
AND REQUIRING THE SECRETARY
INDIAN BE TO TRAIN RELEVANT
STAFF AND HOW THE MOTOR VOTER
SYSTEM WORK. BY CLEARLY
DEFINING TIMELINE FOR DMB TO
PROCESS MOTOR VOTER RECORD THIS
TO ALSO ENSURE THAT ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT
DISENFRANCHISED BECAUSE OF
BACKLOGS AND DMV'S MILGRAM ARE
INITIATED READ TATE. DESPITE
THE SIGNIFICANT ACHIEVEMENT THE
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM PHARMACY
DONE TO PERMANENTLY SECURE
RECENT IMPROVEMENTS AND TO
BRING THREE MILLION ELIGIBLE
BUT UNREGISTERED CALIFORNIANS
INTO OUR DEMOCRACY. EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY SIX OF THE
PRACTICAL GOOD GOVERNMENT
MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR EITHER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO WITNESSES IN FAVOR BUT LET
ME- REMIND PEOPLE OF THE
PARTICIPANT CALL IN INFORMATION
IF THEY WISH TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING. THAT PHONE NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE EIGHT
THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE EIGHT.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO TWO
THREE NINE ONE SEVEN OUR-
MODERATOR I DON'T SEE ANYONE
ANYONE ELSE IN HERE IN THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
SEE NOW WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU ASK
THERE'S ANYONE THERE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
AB. SEVEN NINE SIX. THANK YOU
TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE FOUR LINES IN Q.
IT WILL BE JUST A MOMENT BEFORE
WE HAVE OUR FIRST. AND WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT OUR MIND
DOES- THAT UPS BECAUSE WE'VE
ALREADY HAD LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE JUST SIMPLY ASK THAT
YOU GIVE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU MODERATOR
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU WILLSTART
WITH LINE THIRTY SEVEN THREE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
HEARING MEMBERS WILL MARK ON
BEHALF OF HOW LONG PROFITS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN NINETY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU CAN STONE
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
ENTHUSIASTIC THE COURT. THANK
YOU. NINE THIRTY. THREE ZERO
HELLO THIS IS HELLO THIS IS A
LEASE CONTRACT FROM CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS.
THANK YOU. YOU GOOD. NINE
THIRTY NINE THREE NINE. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ANDREW MEANS
PRESSURE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE LINE THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING KEVIN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NO FOR THE LINE
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME TERRIFIC THANK YOU- WE'RE
GOING TO NOW GO TO OPPOSITION
TO- AT AB SEVEN NINE SIX IS
THERE ANYONE HERE AT THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE IN OPPOSITION. AND
ON ANY LEAD OPPOSITION- LISTED
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
MODERATOR IF YOU ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE THERE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO. TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AB
SEVEN NINE SIX. THANK YOU TO
SHARE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO.
THERE ARE NO PHONE LINES IN Q.
THREE AFFECT WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATORS. C. NINE UP CENTERED
IN THE. TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL VERSION SENATOR
NEWMAN HAS A- MOVED THAT THIS
BILL AS AMENDED- GO FORWARD THE
CONSOLE WOULD CALL THE ROLL. AB
SEVEN NINE SIX THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
GLAZER HI IZURVIVE NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG LEYVA AYE LIVER AYE
NEWMAN NEWMAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THAT- BILLET JOYS THAT LOTS OF
THREE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION WILL MOVE NOT
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FIFTEEN
NINETY FROM THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS SHARE BERMAN THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR AND
CENTERS AB FIFTY NINETY IS ONE
OF THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE'S ANNUAL OMNIBUS
BILLS CONTAINING MINOR AND NON
CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT. THIS BILL
INCLUDES CHANGES TO STATE LAW
THAT WERE REQUESTED BY THE F.
PPC THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION AND OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES IDENTIFIED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF A. B. FIFTY
NINETY IS SUPPORTED BY THE F.
T. P. C. AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
THANKS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CHAIR- BERMAN I
UNDERSTAND LINDSAY IN THE CONDO
FROM THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION AS YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESS YES SIR A KEY
HERE IN THE ROOM OR ON THE
PHONE LINES. WITH LIKE ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR WOULD YOU
ASK MS MCCONNELL TO PLEASE
PRESENTED TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
ALLOW IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LINDSAY MCCONNELL AND
I'M LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FOR THE
FOR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION IF HE SEES THE STATE
COMMISSION THAT ADMINISTERS AND
ENFORCES THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT WHICH REGULATE CAMPAIGN
FINANCING CONFLICT OF INTEREST
LOBBYING AND GOVERNMENTAL
ETHICS COMMISSION IS PLEASED
THAT THE PART EIGHTY FIFTEEN
NINETY. EIGHTY FIFTY NINETY IN
CARTRIDGE WITH THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR PENALTY PROVIDED IN
SECTION EIGHT FOUR ONE ON ONE
DOT FIVE THE GOVERNMENT CODE IS
THE EXCLUSIVE PENALTY FOR
VIOLENT VIOLATION OF THAT
SECTION OR WHETHER THE FTC MAY
ENTER IT'S BROADENED FORSMAN AT
THIRTY UNDER THE TRA BECAUSE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES. AB NINETY
A MEANT THAT XIN EIGHT FOUR ONE
NOT FIVE FOR SOUTH OF COURSE BY
TWO. ENFORCEMENT STORY FOR THAT
THAT FROM THE FTP TO THE AT THE
LAST. SECOND THOUGHT COLLECTION
OF THE ORIGINAL P. AND- UNDER
THE PHOTO WITH A- IN THE BILL
THE REQUESTED THE COMMISSION I
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. FOR THE
SYSTEMS AND RESOLVING THIS
QUESTION AND THIS COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING THE BILL TODAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THEIR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER KHANNA WILL GO
TO OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
SCENE NINE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR WOULD YOU QUEUE
UP ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SURE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL ONLY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO THERE ARE NO LINES
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. RIGHT
WITH THAT WILL GO TO- SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION I DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD WITH THIS IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
C. NINE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR WOULD YOU ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
FIFTEEN NINETY TWO. SO INDICATE.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO TO SHARE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AGAIN THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE NO
PHONE LINES IN Q. VERY GOOD
WILL BRING THE MATTER OF FACT
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS SENATOR NEWMAN-
DAVIS DIRECT I JUST LIKE TO
POINT OUT TO MR BERMAN JUST
HELPED A COOPERATIVE AND
RESPECTFUL THIS COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN TO HIM IF ANY MEMBERS THIS
MEDICAL RECORDS COMMITTEE. I
WOULD HOPE FOR RECIPROCAL
TREATMENT AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO MOVE- ALI RECOGNIZE
HALF OF THAT. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM CENTER NEWMAN- NO FOR
THEIR AND QUESTIONS- JERRY
BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DO MY BUT I CAN'T-
MEET THE STANDARDS OF THIS
COMMITTEE EVERY TIME BUT I DO
MY BEST EVERY DIME OF
APPRECIATE- FOLKS SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
VERY GOOD- WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR NEWMAN- AT THE
CONSOLE WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
FOR AB FIFTEEN NINETY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS GLAZER HI
GLAZER AYE NIELSEN. HERTZBERG
LEYVA HI RIVERSIDE NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN AYE THE BILL HAS THREE
VOTES IN FAVOR WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OF THE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK EACH YEAR THANK YOU
CENTERS. I THINK THAT INCLUDES
THE WORK OF ART TODAY. WELL I
THINK THERE'S ONE MORE. LIKE. I
HAVE ITEM THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARC LIKE WELCOME YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE GLIDER PLANE GOT ON
WE WERE ABOUT THE- PLANE YEAH.
YEAH WELL SAID. WE- INVITES YOU
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL THANK YOU
WASN'T SURE IF YOU PUT ON THE
OR I WASN'T. AND I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO TRY TO. FINESSE THIS
BILL I KNOW IT'S GONNA BE
DOUBLE REFERRED TO WE'RE GOING
TO. ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RELATED TO SOME OF THE
OTHER COUNTY ELECTIONS I KNOW-
CENTER AND NEWMAN I LIVE
DISCUSSIONS ON THE NEXT
COMMITTEE IF WE PASSED TODAY.
THIS IS ABOUT ICREASING.
POLITICAL PARTICIPATION IN SOME
OF OUR COUNTY WIDE ELECTIONS
AND HAVE THE MOST IMPACT ON OUR
COUNTY RESIDENTS. ARE THE
OFFICES OF SPECIFICALLY D. A.
AND SHERIFF HAVE TREMENDOUS
IMPACT ON RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT
COUNTY AND HISTORICALLY THEY'VE
BEEN SELECTED- BY VOTERS WHEN
THE FEWEST AMOUNT OF VOTERS
SHOW UP IN THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
DIVERSITY AMONG THOSE VOTERS. I
SHOWS UP AS WELL. IF YOU LOOK
ACROSS THE STATE AND SOME OF
THE PRESIDENTIAL FIRST
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTIONS IT'S
NIGHT AND DAY AS FAR AS- A
POLITICAL PARTICIPATION. AND
THE REPRESENTATION OF THE
VOTERS. IT DOESN'T ALWAYS
EQUATE WHAT THE STATE LOOKS
LIKE. THIS THIS ELECTION IS A
VERY SIMPLE PREMISE. ON ON THE
MOST IMPORTANT LESSONS THAT
AFFECT OUR COMMUNITIES WE WANT
TO HAVE THE GREATEST. NUMBER OF
PEOPLE VOTING. THIS IN INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND FOR OF COLOR.
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON
THIS IN THE NEXT COMMITTEES OUT
PASSED TODAY. AND ADDRESS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SOLELY
FOCUSED ON- THE SHERIFF AND DA
AND ALLOW MORE LOCAL CONTROL.
FOR THE ASSESSOR ANOTHER.
ELECTIONS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COUNTIES
ASIDE IF THIS IS ENACTED INTO
LAW. WHETHER IMPLEMENTATION OUT
OF THE GATE WOULD BE A TWO YEAR
SIX YEAR TERM-WITH INITIAL
IMPLEMENTATION I WITH ME IS A
LIGAMENT VOTERS TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY NUMBER I UNDERSTAND
ANDREW MUSE FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS IS YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT- SHE
HERE. I SEE HERE IN THIS ROOM
NOW HE'S ON THE PHONE LINE SO
MODERATE WOULD YOU ASK- MR MUSA
FISHER TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
WE'VE GOT A GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING HER GLAZER
NUMBER THAT THE ENGINE
STRUCTURE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS CALIFORNIA. IS
VALUED AT EIGHT FIVE ET AND
NINE. NINE NINE AND I'D LIKE TO
QUICKLY EXTRACT APPRECIATION
FOR EVERYTHING ON THE NET. I'M
BEGIN TO ADOPT OUT ACROSS.
ENQUIRE THAT THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED. BILLINGSLEY THE
MARKET A STRONG AND WHENEVER
ACTIONS. HYDRATE OUT FIRST YEAR
VOTER. WHILE DALLAS AND
ELECTIONS TRACK THE UCBCP
MARKERS AND GUBERNATORIAL
ELECTION. IT ALSO BACK UP
ACTION THAT TRIED TO MORE. BODY
PLAYERS ACCORDING TO THE
FRANKLIN SCHOOL YOU THE
NOVEMBER. EIGHTEEN IT'S CLEAR
THAT LEFT INTERNET CHANNEL
ACTION BY SMALLER LESS
REPRESENTATIVE FIRST YEAR
COLLEGE BOOK. OF WHAT THE DARK.
AB SEVENTY NINE ONE ONE
OWNERSHIP COUNTY. A LOT MORE
UNDERREPRESENTED VOTERS TO KEEP
RECALL LOCAL DIVISION HELLO
THERE CURRENTLY PHILLIP CHEN
WILL BE AN ACCOUNTABILITY OF
LOCAL. INTERNALIZING COULD
VOTERS BOTH THE CAN YOUR- IT'S
CRITICAL TO MAKING THAT MAKING
A MOCKERY WORKS. FOR REASON THE
LEGAL BUYERS. JOHNSON AB. FIVE
I THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THE
PARTY CURRENTLY ON THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH WILL
GO TO OTHER. HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE IN FAVOR-
SCENERY GO TO THE PHONE LINES
ASK THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN FAVOR TO JUST PROVIDE THEIR
NAME AND THEIR AFFILIATION. AND
SUPPORT FOR THIS LEGISLATION
MODERATOR WOULD YOU INVITE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SEVEN FIVE NINE
PLEASE DO SO NOW. THANK YOU WE
PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE ALSO
SURE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
MCGINNIS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE THIRTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE AT THE
SHOCK HAPPEN THE K. FACT AT THE-
FOR. THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
THIRTY RESERVE. HELLO THIS IS
THE LEAST CONTRACT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
AND SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. IT
WILL NOW GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
I UNDERSTAND THERE IS A LEAD
OPPONENT. MISTER JOHN AT TO DO
YOUR- WITH NAPA COUNTY- NOT
PRESENT HERE IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE ASSUME HE'S ON THE
PHONE LINES- MODERATOR WOULD
YOU INVITE HIM TO PLEASE
PROVIDE US TESTIMONY NOW. THANK
YOU NOT LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
GLAZER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN TUTOR NAPA COUNTY
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS IN MY FORTY
THIRD YEAR IS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN NAPA COUNTY AND MY
TWENTY THIRD YEAR AS REGISTRAR
OF VOTERS- THERE'S A BASIC
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL AND THAT
IS THIS IDEA THAT GREATER
TURNOUT IN LOCAL ELECTIONS WILL
OCCUR IN PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARIES. IN MY VIEW THE EXACT
OPPOSITE IS TRUE. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE- IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THE DROP OFF FROM
GOVERNOR TO THE NEXT- CONTEST
ON THE BALLOT WHICH IS HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES WAS EIGHT POINT
THREE FOUR PERCENT. IN JUNE OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY THE DROP OFF FROM
PRESIDENT TO HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES WAS FORTY THREE
POINT 7% THAT'S 35% INCREASE IN
DROP OFF HAS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT ALL OF THE VOTERS
THAT WERE MENTIONED EARLIER WHO
DO TURN OUT FOR THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THE GREAT
MAJORITY OF THEM ONLY VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT. THEY DO NOT VOTE
DOWN BALLOT ISSUES. AND ADDING
ANY LOCAL OFFICIALS TO THE
BALLOT. MAKE THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY EVEN MORE COMPLICATED
THAN IT IS ALREADY. THOSE RACES
ARE FOR A REASON ON THE
STATEWIDE GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY
THE MAIN REASON IS TO BALANCE
THE NUMBER OF CONTESTS ON THE
BALLOT. SO THAT THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY WHICH IS
ALREADY LONG CONFUSING AND WITH
MULTIPLE BALLOTS CARDS WILL NOT
GET WORSE. THE FINAL POINT I
WANTED TO MAKE IS THAT THE
STATEWIDE OFFICERS INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER ATTORNEY GENERAL
ETCETERA ARE ALL ON THE
GUBERNATORIAL PRIMARY. AND IT
MAKES SENSE THAT LOCAL
OFFICIALS WHO CARRY OUT
FUNCTIONS SUCH AS THAT LIKE THE
DA THE SHERIFF. AND THE COUNTY
CLERK REMAIN ON THE-
GUBERNATORIAL STATEWIDE PRIMARY
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND I HAVE ASKED FOR
A VOTE AGAINST THANK YOU MISTER
TUTOR FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WILL
GO TO ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. HERE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE C. NINE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES AT.
THE SAME- GUIDANCE TO THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION TO POLICE JUST NOW
PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR WOULD YOU
INVITE THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO SEVEN
FIVE NINE. TO SO INDICATE.
THANK YOU TO SHARE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL MANY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE TWENTY
TWO TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
NUMBER KAREN LAYING ON THE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNTY TREASURER AND TAX
COLLECTOR. WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL IN FRANCE BUT IT
SOUNDS ABOUT THE COMMISSION TO
TAKE AN AMENDMENT CERTAINLY OF
THE COUNTY. YEAH ATTACK OF THE
BILL ON COUNTY TREASURE'S AND
WITH THAT I THINK THAT WOULD
WITH OUR OPPOSITION. WITH
WITHIN THAT TIME FRAME THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE LINE. TWENTY
NINE. HELLO RIGHT ROCKER
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS WERE OPPOSED
IN OUR LETTERS FORTHCOMING. WE
HAVE LINE THIRTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CORY CELLS L. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THERE FOR NO FURTHER LINES
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATE WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. I'LL GO
FIRST IF THAT'S OKAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL I KNOW YOUR INTENTIONS
ARE GOOD AND I APPRECIATED THE
OPPORTUNITY WE'VE HAD TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS- PRIOR
TO WORK- HEARING TODAY- FOR ME
AT LEAST IF YOUR BILL WAS TO
GIVE OPTIONS TO THE LOCALS. IN
TERMS OF- WHERE THEY COULD
CHOOSE TO PUT THEIR ALEXION'S
IDEA ALL IN FAVOR OF THAT. BUT
BECAUSE IT'S A MANDATE- ON ON
EVERY COUNTY- I HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE BILL LITTLE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY. I DID FIND-
SOMEONE KNOW WHERE THE POINT
THAT WAS RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS- THAT NOT ABOUT NINETY
FIVE PERCENT. OF THESE COUNTY
ALL ELECTIONS ARE SETTLED IN
THE PRIMARY IN THE PRIMARY. SO
WHAT YOUR BILL AT THAT- CARRIED
FORWARD WOULD REALLY MEAN IS
THAT EFFECT ABOUT FIVE PERCENT-
THAT WOULDHAVE THAT MATTERS
THAT MOVING TO THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION VERSES THAT. THAT THE
PRIMARY ELECTION AND A LOT OF
THE ISSUES THAT THAT THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED ABOUT. THE GOALS
FOR THE BILL IN TERMS OF
PARTICIPATION- PRETTY PRETTY
MODEST- CHANGES THAT I CAN SEE
AT LEAST IN TERMS OF THE
PRIMARY- TURNOUT- I WOULD ALSO.
NOTE THAT. THERE ARE SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH- WE
HEARD THE THIRD TO THE
REGISTRAR FROM THE COUNTY. OF
NAFTA TALK ABOUT THE DROP OFF
RATE- IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT IN
PRESIDENTIAL RACES. YET THE
COST OF RUNNING IN A
PRESIDENTIAL RACE IS
DRAMATICALLY HIGHER- BECAUSE OF
THE POTENTIAL AT LEAST FOR A
GREATER PARTICIPATION WHICH ON%
ONE HAND IS A GOOD THING. ON
THE OTHER HAND IT'S BALANCED
OUT BY SOME CONSEQUENCES FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO GET THEIR
MESSAGES OUT. AT NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF A COST. PERSPECTIVE
BUT ALSO FROM THE IS GETTING
THE ATTENTION OF THE VOTERS TO
THAT CONTEST ITSELF. AS WE KNOW
IN THESE PRESIDENTIAL RACES
IT'S KINDA SUCKS THE OXYGEN.
OUT OF THE ROOM FOR A LOT OF
THAT. REPORTING THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SEE EITHER ONLINE OR
BROADCAST MEDIA FOR SOME OF THE
OTHER RACES THAT WE ARE-
FOLLOWING. SO WITH THAT I- WITH
ALL RESPECT I'M NOT GOING TO
JOINING YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL TODAY I UNDERSTAND YOU MAY
HAVE THE VOTES TO MOVE THE BILL
FURTHER. FORWARD IN ANY CASE
AND THAT'S THAT'S PERFECTLY
FINE BUT I DID WANT TO RAISE
THOSE ISSUES- WITH YOU IF YOU
WISH TO ADDRESSING YOU CAN'T WE
CAN GO TO OTHER COLLEAGUES FOR
COMMENTS. YEAH I'D AM WELL
THANK YOU FOR RAISING THOSE
ISSUES AND I DID WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT THE OP THE
OPPOSITION. THE TWO LATER
CALLS- WERE SIMILAR TO THEM THE
MAIN UPON IT AND ALL DRESSED
THAT HIS HIS THREE ISSUES AS
WELL. AS AS YOU KNOW THE TAX
COLLECTORS AND THE OTHER COUNTY
OFFICES OTHER THAN SHERIFF AND
DA. THOSE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
PART OF THE BILL SO I THINK
THOSE. ARE A BIT MOVE ON ON THE
ISSUE AS FAR AS HAVING A DROP
OFF. IN THE PRESIDENTIAL A
CERTAINLY THERE IS BUT I WOULD
ARGUE THAT EVEN THE DROP OFF.
WITH THE DROP OFF IS STILL FAR
GREATER POLITICAL
PARTICIPATION. ESPECIALLY AMONG
OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND
HAVING IT. IN THE GUBERNATORIAL
YEAR AND THEN AS FAR AS- THE
PRIMARY VERSES THE GENERAL THAT
WOULD BE THE SAME WAY WHETHER
IT'S IN. A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION OR A- FOR I DO
MAJORITY OVER SAYS THE PRIMARY.
THERE'S ONLY TWO CANDIDATES
GOING ON. ONTO THE GENERAL SO I
DO THINK THAT WE'VE ADDRESSED-
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES. AND THEN-
A- THE MAIN CONCERNS WE HEARD
THERE THEY WILL BE ADDRESSED
THE NEXT COMMITTEE ONLY ONLY
FOCUSING ON. THE TOP TWO ISSUES
OF THE SHERIFF AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. VERY GOOD OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS SENATOR
NEWMAN- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SO I DO APPRECIATE THE CHEERS-
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS IT. WAS
RECORDED WHEN I WANT TO COMMEND
YOU FOR. YOUR WILLINGNESS. TO
BE THROUGH A THOUGHTFUL AND
DELIBERATE ABOUT THIS- AND AS
WE'VE DISCUSSED. THE TWO
POSITIONS AT ISSUE HERE DA AND
SHERIFF- ARE IMPORTANT I THINK
IN THE LAST YEAR. WE HAVE SEEN.
I JUST HOW IMPORTANT THESE TO
PUBLIC SAFETY POSITIONS. ARE
AND TO YOUR POINT YOUR GOAL- A
MORE REPRESENTATIVE MORE
DIVERSE ELECTORATE- IS CLEARLY
A GOOD THING WHEN IT COMES TO
DETERMINE WHO WILL STE WHO WILL
SERVE IN THOSE POSITIONS- SO
WITH THAT- BUT I. YOU KNOW GAD
TO SUPPORT THE BILL BUT RESPECT
THE SBA L. AS A CO AUTHOR AS IT
MOVES THROUGH- AND HAVE BEEN
MOVED THE BILL IN THE TIMES
PROGRAM. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS- C. NINE
A CELL NUMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT DEBATE- THAT PRECIADO THE
CONSIDERATION ASKREDDIT. THREAD
I RECOGNIZE THE MOTION FOR THE
SENATOR NEWMAN- TO- DO PATHS-
THIS BILL THROUGH- THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE. AND
FINANCE. WITH THAT AS THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB SEVEN FIVE NINE MO IS TO.
THE FIRST RE. TO THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
GLAZER NOPE GLAZER NO NIELSEN.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE LIVE A
LIFE LEYVA HI NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN
I. REFLECT THAT YOUR BILL HAS
THREE VOTES WERE GONNA LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALL RIGHT THAT
BRINGS US TO THE LAST- IT
MATTER ON OUR AGENDA- ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. C. A. ONE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG WELCOME. AND
YOU CAN PRESENT IN YOUR DESK IF
YOU LIKE. THANK. GEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR. I HAVE BEEN A-
DILIGENT STUDENT OF THE DIRECT
DEMOCRACY THIS YEAR'S FOR MANY
DECADES. YOU WILL FIND THIS
BOOK ON MY DESK CALL CALIFORNIA
ISSUES IN REFERENDUMS NINETEEN
TWELVE TO NINETEEN NINETY BUT
THE PAT BROWN INSTITUTE. AND
DAVID BRODER WHO I INTERVIEWED
WITH ON DEMOCRACY DERAILED.
INITIATIVE CAMPAIGNS AND WHEN I
SERVED IN MY LAST JOB I HAD A
COMMISSION ON INITIATIVE
REFORM. AND ALSO WAS DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN THE- AT THE COUPLE
OF YOUR EFFORT THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER WITH RON GEORGE SHE
WITH THE- COMMON CAUSE GROUP
AND A HOST OF OTHERS- TO REFORM
INITIATIVES. ALL OF WHICH ARE
INFORMED BY THE UNDER THE
BANNER OF DIRECT DEMOCRACY
WHICH CAME UNDER HIRAM JOHNSON.
WHAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF DIRECT
DEMOCRACY DIRECT DEMOCRACY CAME
AT A TIME WHEN THE RAILROADS.
AT THE END INAPPROPRIATE
INFLUENCE ON THIS PLACE. AND
BOND THERE WAS EXTRAORDINARY
CORRUPTION AND THIS WAS A WAY
TO GIVE POWER TO THE PEOPLE.
POWER TO THE PEOPLE TO OVERTURN
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE DOES.
WOULD YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENED THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS WE'VE SEEN IT IN THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS WITH
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BEING SPENT BY OUTSIDE INTEREST
GROUPS WE'VE SEEN IT IN THE
REFERENDUM PROCESS. SIMILAR
KIND OF A THING HAPPENING IF
YOU LOOK FOR EXAMPLE IN THIS
PAT BROWN INSTITUTE BOOK IT'LL
SHOW YOU THAT JUST VISTA
HANDFUL WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF INITIATIVES FOR
EXAMPLE THE REFERENCED
APPROPRIATELY IN YOUR ANALYSIS.
VERY FEW IN THE EARLY YEARS AND
THEN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
NINETY NINE IT WAS FORTY FOUR
AT OVER FORTY S. SIXTY ONE. TO
pNEXT NUMBER OF SIXTY ONE OF THE
NEXT NUMBER OF YEARS THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
MOVEMENT AFOOT. BY OUTSIDE
INTEREST GROUPS AS WE HAVE MORE
TELEVISION MORE ABILITY TO
INFLUENCE THE PROCESS TO
DRAMATICALLY UP USE THIS TOOL
THAT WAS INITIALLY INTENDED TO
GIVE POWER TO THE PEOPLE AND
NOW IT'S EXCEPT THE APT IMPACT
IS EXACTLY OPPOSITE AND
REFERENDUMS. ARE PARTICULARLY
TROUBLESOME. BECAUSE THE IN
THIS IS WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET
TO IN THIS MEASURE. IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKES AN ACTION.
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR PASSED
BY BOTH HOUSES. AND THEN ALL OF
A SUDDEN INTEREST GROUP COMES
ALONG AND SAYS WE DON'T LIKE
THE OUTCOME WE'RE GOING TO
WRITE A CHECK AND CHANGE THE
GAME. WE SEE IT NOW COMING UP
ON THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BALLOT WITH TOBACCO.
THEY'RE SEEKING TO REFERENDUM
CENTRE HILLS MEASURE SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE. THEY'VE ALREADY
RAISED TWENTY ONE POINT ONE
MILLION TEN MILLION DOLLARS A
LOAN FROM RJ REYNOLDS. IS THAT
THE WAY TO GOVERN. IT YOU START
WITH THE INDIAN GAMING SOME
YEARS AGO I WAS INVOLVED IN
THAT ONE IS PRIVATE LAWYER WE
SEEDED IT WITH RESPECT TO
PODERES AND DALY OWNS IN LARGE
MEASURE ON. IN AND PROP SIXTY
SEVEN IN IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THE
THING THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
CORRECT HERE. CERTAINLY BURKE
THE REFERENDUM IS AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT WHICH BASICALLY SAYS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A MECHANISM
TO WILL BE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
OVERTURN WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOES A FAIR AND APPROPRIATE
POWER BUT IT HAS TO BE
EXERCISED IN A MANNER. THAT IS
FAIR AND WHAT'S HAPPENED AND
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO CORRECT IN
THIS MEASURE ARE TOO THANKS.
IT'S CONFUSING BECAUSE WHEN
SOME VOTER COMES ALONG AND
VOTES FOR YES OR NO ON THE
BALLOT SUPPORT TO UNDERSTAND
THE CONTEXT THE VOTING YES OR
NO ON ALL THE INITIATIVES AND
THEN THEY HAVE A FLIPPED.
RESPONSIBLE YES MEANS WHAT A NO
MEANS WITH RESPECT TO A
REFERENDUM IT'S QUITE CONFUSING
SO CONFUSING THAT I GOT CALLS
AND STREAM IMPORTANT ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO TOLD ME THEY
THOUGHT THAT THEY HAD VOTED ON
A MEASURE ONE WAY THE NAY VOTE
ANOTHER BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT
DO YOU ESTIMATE I WOULDN'T
MATTER. SECOND UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION THE WAY THE
ORDERING HAPPENS IS THAT
REFERENDUMS AT THE BOTTOM WOULD
YOU WE CLEARLY KNOW IN THIS
LAST ELECTION OVER A MILLION
PEOPLE WHO VOTED THE TOP OF THE
BALLOT. DROPPED OFF BECAUSE
VOTER FATIGUE AND INVOLVED THE
BOTTOM OF THE BALLOT. BUT IF
EVERY OTHER CON. IT'S PUT IN
ORDER OF QUALIFICATION. SO YOU
KNOW HAVE THEM IF YOU DON'T%
HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR IN THE
L. DULY ELECTED IN THE ENDEAVOR
TO WHO ARE BEING ELECTED AND
THEN YOU HAVE A PROCESS THAT IS
COMPLETELY RIGGED IN THE SENSE
OF BOTH CONFUSION. AND VOTER
FATIGUE AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE IS TO CHANGE THAT
PROCESS TO PUT IN A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD NO ONE'S TAKING
AWAY THE POWER OF THE PEOPLE
THE REFERENDA SOMETHING WE'RE
TRYING TO DO ESPECIALLY NOW
WE'RE SEEING MORE AND MORE
THESE REFERENDUMS COMING ALONG
A TO OVERTURN WITH THE
LEGISLATURE DOZEN I WOULD
SUGGEST IT'S BECAUSE THE YOU
KNOW. THERE'S THE LEGISLATURE
IS COULD IS MORE CONTROLLED BY
ONE PARTY VERSUS ANOTHER AND
THAT HAPPENS. AND SO. BUT
THAT'S A REFLECTION OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THE REDISTRICTING
IS DONE IN THE DISTRICTS ARE
CHOSEN. NOT BY SOME
GERRYMANDERING PROCESS BUT BY A
COMPLETELY NONPARTISAN FAIR
PROCESS AND JUST REFLECTS WHO
WE ARE AS A STATE WE CAN LIKE
IT OR NOT LIKE IT. BUT IT
REFLECTS WHO WE ARE AS A STATE.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS RIGGED. IN
THE IN IN THAT IT IT IS TOTALLY.
AGAINST AT THE FAIR APPROACH IT
CREATES A PROCESS. WHERE A YES
AND EVERY OTHER INITIATIVE
YOU'RE GOING DOWN THE LIST YOU
GET TO THE END AND IT FLIPS.
YOU CAN'T LOOK AT IT OUT OF
CONTEXT NOW. JUST LATE
OPPOSITION BY THE CALCHAMBER
SAYS. IT CITES A CASE CALLED
STRAUSS FOR HIS HORTON. WELL
WHEN BOB HERTZBERG NAY THEY
GIVE THIS TO ME AT THE LAST
MINUTE I OF COURSE READ THE
CASE. BECAUSE I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT IT SAYS IS IT SUPPORTING
THEIR POSITION. AND BASICALLY
THE ARGUMENT IS THAT THIS
DOESN'T CONSTITUTE A REVISION.
BUT THAT THIS CONSTITUTES A- A
FAR REACHING CHANGE THE NATURE
OF OUR BASIC GOVERNMENT PLAN.
WE LOOK AT THAT CASE AND THAT
CASE DEALT WITH PROPOSITION.
EIGHT IN IN IN SAME SEX
MARRIAGES. AND WHAT THE COURT
SAYS IN THAT IS SPECIFICALLY A
CHANGE IN THE COST IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. IS
REVISION ONLY IF IT INVOLVES A
CHANGE THAT IS SUCH FAR
REACHING SCOPE. THAT IT
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES THE
RELATION OF GOVERNMENT IN THIS
CASE VESTS ALL JUDICIAL POWER
IN THAT CASE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT IS NOT
HAPPENING HERE AND TO ME YOU
KNOW IT'S A LITTLE UNFAIR IN
TERMS OF WHOEVER WROTE THAT
LETTER. TO BE ABLE TO CHEN WILL
MAYBE THE LAST GIVEN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO TRY TO MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT BY THROWING A CASE
THAT'S ALREADY OUT TO. WHICH IS
WHAT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME BUT
RATHER THAN LOOKING AT THE
DETAILS OF THE CASE. YOUR
ANALYSIS CITES A CASE WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH. AN APPROPRIATE
WITH RESPECT TO. THE POINT THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE WITH THE
IS THIS SHOULD BE A
CONSTITUTIONAL AS OPPOSED TO
THE STATUTORY APPROACH. TO
SOLVING THIS PROBLEM. YES YES
AND SO. I JUST I JUST THINK
THAT WE'RE WE'RE GOING. HOW
CRITICAL IT IS.AND AT THE END
OF THE DAY WOULD HAVE CA DOES
IS JUST SAY. WITH RESPECT. THE
REFERENDUM PROCESS. LET'S JUST
MAKE IT FAIR SO YES IS A YES
AND NO IS A NO CONSISTENT WITH
ALL THE OTHER VOTES THAT WE ASK
VOTERS. AND TO. PUT IN THE
ORDER. OF HOW THEY QUALIFY JUST
LIKE ANYBODY ELSE RATHER THAN
PUTTING. A REFERENDUM WHICH IS
AGAIN THIS IS NOT SOME PIE IN
THE SKY I THINK IT'S BEEN
VETTED TO THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE. BEEN SIGNED BY
GOVERNOR. AND PUTTING AT THE
END F THE BALLOT WHERE YOU
HAVE VOTER FATIGUE. THAT HAS A
CHILLING EFFECT A WEAPONIZING A
FACT I WOULD ARGUE. AGAINST THE
POWER OF THE ELECTED GOVERNMENT
TO ACT SO YOU WANT A FAIR
PROCESS. AND WITH THAT I'D
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG AND I HAVE A
WITNESS. I JUST ANY OF THE LEAD
WITH AS MUCH EITHER ANDREW MUSE
FISHER FROM THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS CORRECT MODERATOR WOULD
YOU INVITE MISTER. MUSICIAN TO
PROVIDE IS TESTAMENT TO REMIND.
CANNON AND OTHERS THAT WE
PROVIDE TWO MINUTES- EACH. FIVE
ON LEAD WITNESS TESTIMONY. HI
GOOD MORNING AGAIN THAT THE
INTERNET FOR SURE WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. HE IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE A. ONE. WE
BELIEVE THAT HAVING A CLEAR
STATEMENT OF A YES VOTE IN
FAVOR OF IRAQ RENDON COUNTY.
SHINNING NO VOTE AGAINST
BACKGROUND OF TORTURE AND THAT
SHE WOULD GO A LONG WAY. FOR
EACH. THE LEGAL EDUCATE EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO VOTE WITH CONFIDENCE
AND ALLOW. INTERNET BILLING
INFORMATION ISN'T ACCEPTABLE
LANGUAGE AND A CRITICAL PART OF
THE ENTERPRISE. TO THAT END WE
PUBLISH THE EVENING ORDER GUIDE
EVERY I CALL. IN IT WE OFFER
CLEAR UNBIASED ABOUT. IT BUT
FOR. THE RECORD AND THAT WE
HAVE BEEN PUTTING A CALL OUT
BOXES YES BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
IT DOESN'T. REGULATE
PROPOSITIONS. THE PROBLEM IS
THAT THE KERR GREEN COUNTER TO
THAT VOTERS HUNTINGTON BEACH
AND NOT AVAILABLE VOTING
OVERTURN OR PRESERVE A LOT. WE
GET QUITE AT TO WHY AN
ORGANIZATION WITH THE PORT OF
THE LEGISLATION HEY. AND THEN
ERICA YES SO ON THE RECORD AND
I TOLD. HER NOT. THE VOTERS
MONTH AND ABOUT THE VOTE THE
PUBLIC. AFTER ALL WHILE
PROPONENTS ABOUT WHAT ABOUT NOW.
ANOTHER ASSEMBLY NOTED LENGTHS.
RIGHT GAME ONE ONE OUR JOB
EDUCATING VOTERS MY EASIER AND
INCLUDING THE PLAN MEETING
OTHER YOUNG OR NO. SHE WE'RE
ALSO VERY MUCH FAVOR OF OFFICE
TO WORKING A BY MY. BOB BY
ELECTION UP ABOUT ABOUT IT OUR
COPPER BOOK BUT- POLICE REPORT
SB ONE HOW OTHERS ON I MAKING
FOR. WE THANK HERTZBERG
LEADERSHIP AND WE ARE I THOUGHT
THANK YOU THEY YOU VERY MUCH
GOING TO GO AND THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE TO SEE IF THERE'S A
OTHER WITNESSES FAVOR. C. NINE
WILL GO TO THE LINE THAT MATER
YOU CAN ASK THOSE WITH TO TEST
IN SUPPORT OF A CA ONE- TO BE
PER. TO DO SO AND REMIND THEM
THAT WILL JUST TAKE THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATION IN EDUCATION
SUPPORT. THANK YOU YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE AT THIS TIME ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. FIFTY
THREE. I SHOW NO PHONE LINES IN
Q. FOUR SUPPORT OKAY VERY GOOD
MODERATOR THANK YOU WERE MOVED
TO OPPOSITION TO SCA ONE I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THAT CHAMBER IN OUR- IN OUR
MEETING ROOM HERE I MISSED THAT
MUHAMMAD WELCOME TO THE CHAMBER
YOU HAVE A FEW MINUTES AND
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOUR HONOR
THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS OF ANY
TWELVE MOM TO THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT CA ONE-
SCA ONE IN ADDITION TO ITS- ITS
OWN CHANGES BRINGS A CHANGE THE
ELECTION CODE FOUND IN SB FOUR
FORTY THREE. WHICH IS
CONTINGENT ON SCA ONE PASSING
THIS MAY APPEAR AS A TECHNICAL
CHANGE THE STATURE BUT THE
REASONING BEHIND THE SUGGESTION
IS UNSETTLING BECAUSE IN THIS
BILL IT TENDS TO SUGGEST
DEVOTED TO ONE THING OVER
ANOTHER- SB FOUR FORTY THREE
THREATS IS ONE PASSAGE WOULD
CHANGE THE LANGUAGE ON BALLOTS
TO REMOVE THE WORD REJECTED OR
ADOPTED AND LEAVE THE VOTERS
THE CHOICE AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WOULD MERELY REJECT ITEMS
THE WORD REJECTED COMES WITH A
NEGATIVE CONNOTATION AND
LEAVING IT ON THE PAGE ALONG
WITHOUT A BOUNCING TERM LIKE
ADOPTED CREATES AN IMPLIED
SUGGESTION BY THE STATE.
VISUALLY THE TERM REJECTED ON
THE PAGE ALONE LEAVES A MUCH
STRONGER NEGATIVE CONNOTATION
IN THE MIND OF A VOTER THAT CAN
DISCOURAGE VOTERS FROM ACTING
BEFORE REMOVING BOTH CHOICES
FROM THE EYES OF THE VOTER IT
SHOULD BE STUDY TO DETERMINE
HOW THIS AFFECTS A PERSON'S.
WILLINGNESS TO VOTE. ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER. SUCH A CHANGE TO THE
WAY VOTERS. OP A LITTLE ON THE-
TOWARD OUR OPTIONS NOT READ-
THE ULTIMATE POINT OF FAIRNESS
ON OUR ELECTIONS. SB FORTY
THREE. HOWEVER I SUGGEST THAT.
REQUIRES THAT AS A ONE GAME
PASSAGE FIRST. SO IN ADDITION
TO GIVING OPERATIVE WIFE HAS
BEFORE FORTY THREE. SB ONE WILL
REQUIRE THE ADDITION OF NEW
LEGALISTIC DESCRIPTIONS TO THE
BALLOT WHICH IN ADDITION TO ALL
OTHER INFORMATION PRINTED.
STATES THAT A YES VOTE. IS IN
FAVOR OF THE REFERENDUM AND
REJECTS THE STATUTE OR PART OF
THE STATUTES SUBJECT TO THE
REFERENDUM IN A NO VOTE. IS
AGAINST THE REFERENDUM. AND
APPROVED THE STATURE PART OF
STATUTES SUBJECT TO THE
REFERENDUM. THIS IS. UNUSUAL
BECAUSE A REFERENDUM BY ITS
NATURE CALLS. FOR THE REJECTION
OF A STATUTE OR PART OF THE
STATURE. THE RISK IS GREATER
WHEN LOOKING AT THE WAY IN
WHICH LANGUAGES PHRASE FOR
EXAMPLE. EXPLANATIONS REQUIRED
BY A CA ONE. WILL JUXTAPOSE THE
WORD YES WITH THE DEFINITION
DESCRIBING REJECTION. AND WE'RE
NOW WITH LANGUAGE APPROVAL.
HOWEVER THESE FOREGOING
REASONS. AND OTHERS AS NOTED IN
OUR LETTER WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO WHEN I SEE ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIFIED TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
HERE AT ONE THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THE NINE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE. MY AT. THAT ANYBODY
THANK YOU THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION I REMIND
THEM THAT IN THIS POINT IN THE
HEARING WILL ONLY TAKE THEIR
NAME AND AFFILIATION. AND THEIR
OPPOSITION TO SCA ONE. THANK
YOU TO SHARE YOUR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL ME PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE OF THE BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. RIGHT WILL BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. THAT ARE IN THE- THE
YES THANK YOU MISTER IN THE
THROUGH THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY A
QUESTION FOR MR MOHAMMED- JANET
SO I'M INTRIGUED. BY THE POINT
YOU MADE WITH RESPECT TO
LANGUAGE- IN THE ELIMINATION OF
THE WORD- ADOPTED. SURE YOU
SURE YOU ARGUE THAT IT SHOULD
BE STUDY IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
TELLING US HOW HOW HOW MIGHT
YOU STUDY THAT- SHORT OF
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING THE-
PROVISION IS PROPOSED. YES YOUR
HONOR IF I MAY SO- WITH REGARD
TO STUDYING THE LANGUAGE- THERE
THERE IS ACTUALLY A PROCESS
WHEREBY BALLOTS ARE ARE STUDIED
FOR FORM- FOR THE GRAPHIC
DESIGN FOR THE CONTENT IN THE
LANGUAGE. THESE TYPES OF
CHANGES TYPICALLY WOULD BE AB
TESTED RIGHT AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE'S A TENDENCY FOR
VOTERS. TO HAVE THEIR OPINIONS
ADJUSTED WILL BE SUGGESTED OR
IMPLIED ONE DIRECTION OR THE
OTHER BASED ON THE LANGUAGE ON
PAGE. PRECIADO IT YOU'RE VERY
GOOD AT SHORT I. I'VE- BECOME
SOMETHING OF A STUDENT OF- THE
WORK OF HIRAM JOHNSON IN THE
REST OF THE GUYS WHO FORMS- AND
I WANT TO SAY. SPECIFICALLY TO
THE BILL LIKE I AGREE WITH
CENTER HERTZBERG A YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY- THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED A GREAT DEAL SINCE
NINETEEN TWELVE- PARTICULAR THE
POLITICAL WORLD- AND THE
INFLUENCE OF MONEY AND
SIGNATURE GATHERING WITHIN THAT
WORLD- I THINK THIS IS A VERY
REASONABLE AND COMMONSENSE.
APPROACH BOTH WITH RESPECT TO
THE LANGUAGE BUT ALSO TO PUT
TO. RANGING REFERENDA TO THE
TOP OF THE BALLOT IF
SOMETHING'S IMPORTANT FOR
VOTERS TO CONSIDER. A LET'S
HAVE AS MANY VOTERS AS POSSIBLE
PARTICIPATE- AND LET'S HAVE
THEM DO SO INTELLIGENTLY AND
WON'T FOR PATIENTS SO WITH
THAT- WHEN THE TIME TO PROBABLY
LOOK TO MOVE THE BILL. I'VE
BEEN THINKING THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN. AT CENTER HERTZBERG AYE
UP HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY I SUPPORTED US BEFORE FOR
THREE EARLIER I THINK THE
GOALS. ARE LAUDATORY AND I
THINK ARE ACCOMPLISHED BY WHAT
YOU WOULD PUT BEFORE US AND
HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. LIKE
SENATOR HERTZBERG CLOSE. THANK
YEAH I JUST WANTED TO RESPOND
TO THE LATE OPPOSITION BY THE
CHAMBER AND I YOU KNOW I'M
PROBABLY GOING TO BE REAL TOUGH
ON THIS- BUT I JUST THINK IT'S
AROUND LONG ENOUGH TO.
DETERMINE WHAT THE FOREGOING
REASONS AREN'T WITH THE
FOREGOING REASONS AREN'T I'M
CERTAIN IF I HAD COME UP WITH-
THE RIVER AT THE WAY TO MODIFY
THIS IN A IN A WAY THAT WOULD
DEAL WITH THE REASONS THEY
SUGGESTED THEY WOULD STILL
OPPOSE THAT HAPPENS A LOT IN
THIS BUSINESS WHERE PEOPLE GIVE
YOU A SERIES OF RACES BUT
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO COME
ALONG. AND THE REASON OR NOT IS
THAT THE PEOPLE ARE SUPPORTING
THIS ARE THEIR MEMBERSHIP I
DON'T BEGRUDGE THAT THEY SHOULD
ARGUE FOR THE MEMBERSHIP I JUST
DON'T THINK THAT THOSE INTEREST
GROUPS SHOULD CREATE THIS
WEAPONIZING ON LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD AND I THINK THE POINT
THAT WAS MADE- I WHO HAS A
QUESTION BUT IT'S REALLY IS
COUNTERINTUITIVE IF YOU'RE
GOING ON ON THE BALLOT. MAKING
A DECISION AND ALL THE CITY GOT
A FLIP YOUR REASONING THE NEW
TO KNOW WHAT THERE'S A
REFERENDUM AND INITIATIVE IS
IT'S HARD FOR FOLKS TO DO THIS
STUFF YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
GREATEST THINGS IN ALL THE
POLLING THAT I'VE DONE IN ALL
THE DISCUSSION GROUPS THAT IVE
HAD. SO MANY PEOPLE ON THE ONE
HAND YOU SURE THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE ON THE ONE HAND
THEY'RE SO FRUSTRATED WITH LIKE
WHY CAN'T YOU PEOPLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS WHY DO THESE HAVE TO
COME ON THE BALLOT WHY DO I
HAVE TO DETERMINE THESE
QUESTIONS RIGHT SOME OF MY BOND
ISSUES AND SOME WERE
CONSTITUTIONAL IN NATURE. AND
THAT'S THE WAY WE'VE WRITTEN
THE LAW BUT THEY WANT US TO
SOLVE IT AT THE SAME TIME THEY
ALSO WANT TO RESERVE THE POWER
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A CHECK ON
US WHICH IS ALSO APPROPRIATE
BUT THAT POWER SHOULD BE
RESERVED IN A MANNER THAT'S
FAIR STRAIGHTFORWARD EASILY
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR ALL FOLKS
NOT COUNTERINTUITIVE AND NOT
BEING WEAPONIZED AND WE SHIP
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE. TO
REINVIGORATE THE ENERGY AND
ENTHUSIASM. AND WISDOM OF HIRAM
JOHNSON. ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
CENTER HEARD AMERICA THE NOT.
SENT NEWMAN TO- MOVE THIS BILL
FOR. AND DO PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THAT THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
S. C. A. ONE THE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER HI
RESERVE BY NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I LEYVA
AYE LEVER AYE NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN AYE. THAT BILL IS OUT
FOUR TO ONE- WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK OUT OF BILLS THAT- WE HAVE
PASSED OVER FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WANT TO THANK THAT. THE ON TIME
DILIGENCE CENTERS FOR. AND THEY
THEY THEY CAN THEY CAN LEAVE
THEIR WORK HAS BEEN DONE THANK
YOU SO MUCH- SO WE'RE GONNA
START AT THE TOP OF A WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- WHAT WOULD
YOU CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE MOTION IS
TO ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH INCLUDES AS HE TO AB
THREE ONE NINE AND IT BE
FIFTEEN NINETY ONE. NIELSEN
NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG. AYE
HERTZBERG AYE. THAT MEASURES
OUT FIVE ZERO AND CONSULT IF
YOU COULD GIVE AN UPDATE ON THE
ROLE BEFORE YOU'VE GOT CALL THE
ROLL FREE TO THIS. SIX YES OKAY
OKAY THAT BILLS AT THAT EXACT
COUNT AS PROOF FIVE ZERO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NEXT TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO- AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO. HELD A
CALL THE ROLL. AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX MOTIONS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION THE VOTE IS THREE
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
NIELSEN NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE AYE THAT BILL IS
OUT FOUR TO ONE- WILL MOVED
ITEM NUMBER THREE- AB SEVEN
FIVE NINE BY MCCARTY DIESEL
WOULD CALL THE CALL THE ROLL AB
SEVEN FIVE NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE THE VOTE IS THREE
TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
NO. NIELSEN NIELSEN UP THAT
BILLS OUT THREE TO TWO WILL
MOVE NEXT THAT WE WE'VE HAD WE
HAVE A COMPLETE VOTE ON NUMBER
FIVE IS THAT RIGHT CONSULTANT
CORRECT RIGHT SO WE'LL LIVE
NEXT TO ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
SEVEN NINE SIX FIVE SEVEN
MEMBER BERMAN CONSULT WITH OPEN
THE ROLE. AB SEVEN NINE SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION. THE VOTE IS
THREE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI. NIELSEN NO. NIELSEN
NO HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE.
THAT DILUTES OUT FOR ONE NEXT
UP IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. AB
FIFTEEN NINETY BY THE CANADIAN
ELECTIONS OF THE CONSOLE WOULD
OPEN THE ROLE. AB FIFTEEN
NINETY THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
THE VOTE IS THREE ZERO WITH THE
CHAIRMAN HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN
AYE HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE.
THAT FILLS OUT FIVE ZERO AND
FINALLY ITEM NUMBER NINE S. C.
EIGHT FIVE BY. CENTER. GLAZER
TOLD WHEN OPEN THE ROLE. THE HE
A FIVE IS A DOCTOR BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. VOTE IS THREE
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE. THAT BILL IS OUT
FIVE ZERO THAT COMPLETES THE
WORK OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS. AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS- WHEN I THANK ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TODAY'S HEARING
FOR NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING THE
COMMITTEE. OUR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD. THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR- OPTUS
PATIENT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALL
THOSE INVOLVED INCLUDE STAFF-
AND WITH THAT THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS IS A JERK. THANK YOU.